[Music]
Emme peas will decide their position on
the European Green Deal the EU climate
strategy they'll also discuss the just
transition fund which aims to help
countries move away from coal to
renewable energy sources members will
debate the cop15 summit on biodiversity
which will take place in China in
October the Parliament has been vocal
about its concern over the decline in
biodiversity MEP s are calling for
legally binding targets at global and EU
levels MEP s will discuss the escalation
of tensions in Iran and Iraq and the
--use foreign and security policy
Parliament wants to support
multilateralism and stresses the need
for a stronger and united Europe on the
1st of January Croatia took over the
rotating council presidency from Finland
MEP s will debate Croatia's programme
for the next six months which focuses on
sustainable development safety and
reinforcing Europe's position as a
global leader the conference on the
future of Europe is a new initiative
looking at what legal changes are needed
to better prepare the EU for the future
members will debate their ideas and
adopt a resolution on it ahead of
negotiations with the council and the
Commission
[Music]